[Musique]
ils ont tous en commun la fébrilité
d'être sur la scène de la tohu et
d'avoir connu un parcours de vie
difficile
ces jeunes viennent de québec deux des
symboles de vancouver de manawan ou du
nunavik jusqu'à quand pour la première
fois aujourd'hui pour leur numéro
quand quelqu'un monte sur tes épaules et
fun colonna 2 d'après à faire confiance
à l'autre da brat faire confiance n'a
pas communiqué 80 spectacle à bonal
ouattara veut déployer sa voie de la
confiance mais ça montre estime sabbath
il estime de soi pour certains lucie est
une planche de salut que je transmets un
jeu ne l'ont peut-être la rue j'ai
commencé le cirque social de plus en
plus et c'est ça qui me fait un peu
mieux que moi même avons des routines
parce qu'avant j'étais avec désorganisé
j'avais pas de routine j'avais pour
déterrer de garder le job ou claude
camirand et doute jongler le à montréal
et l'autre à une ou doit on a travaillé
toute la semaine avec les inuits ne
change avec mon parcours sans trop
rentrer dans les détails
j'ai eu tendance à caméra fermé puis
m'isoler un peu puis comme beaucoup est
dans la petite salle est vraiment ça
fait vraiment du bien en fait de comme
bouger son corps par peur du ridicule
c'est d'être en groupe se faire
confiance en marge de cette rencontre
des chercheurs ont échangé sur le cirque
social
comment il rejoint bien les jeunes
vivant dans la précarité
par définition il est aussi un peu
marginale alors ça vient rejoindre les
jeunes les plus marginaux qui trouvent
leur compte un petit commence jean grey
avec des foulards
ou tu peux faire des échasses y en a
pour tous les goûts à toutes les mesures
pour tous les corps et puis on prend des
jeunes du monde à votre communauté
souvent très isolés
enfin on réalise qu'on partie d'une
grande famille ce caprice et elles ont
encore qu'on voulait organiser un
événement comme celui-là et the big pink
l'amérique un met pas l'avenir from sur
caen a dû commencer à jouer
une guerre hier j'ai repris avec fred
l'événement cirque askin à porte bien
son nom
kas qui n'a veut dire tout le monde
ensemble en atika mais ici à nourrice
despatie radio canada montréal